vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
que tiene que ver con estimar en qué
punto se intersectan estas dos gráficas
ahora si te das cuenta el grave problema
de esto es que tenemos dos gráficas que
no son
lineales ni son cuadráticas son gráficas
que son completamente no lineales
tenemos gráficas muy raras fíjate bien a
continuación se muestran las gráficas de
l de x que es esta de azul que es el
logaritmo natural de 3 x el logaritmo
natural de 3x y si te das cuenta ésta se
comporta como un logaritmo natural así
que parece ser que es bastante cierta y
r tx rx que es esta de aquí x cuadrada
menos x más 1 entre x es todo esto de
aquí y si te das cuenta eso tampoco es
nada lineal ni nada fácil de estimar
estima las dos soluciones visibles de la
ecuación logaritmo natural de 3x es
igual a r de x qué es x cuadrada menos x
1 todo eso entre x dentro de 0 1 es
decir dentro de los décimos y lo primero
que quiero que veas es que cuando
nosotros trabajamos con funciones que
son fáciles de manejar no se alguna
cuadrática alguna kubica que se
intersecta con una línea recta o algo
así no es tan difícil encontrar las
soluciones si utilizamos un poco de
álgebra o tal vez estimamos la solución
cerca de la calculadora o algo así sin
embargo en esta ocasión tengo dos
ecuaciones completamente no lineales
tengo un sistema de ecuaciones no
lineales y por lo tanto no se ve nada
fácil encontrar el punto de intersección
entre estas dos curvas y de hecho es
justo lo que nos piden en el punto en el
que rx y lx voy a poner primero que es
con este color ld x que es justo esta de
aquí ésta es l de x
de x ok estoy buscando en el punto en el
que l de x es exactamente igual es
exactamente igual que esta función de
aquí que por cierto es r de x o dicho de
otra manera cuando estoy buscando que
las dos funciones sean iguales estoy
buscando el punto en donde se
intersectan realmente lo que estamos
buscando es este punto de aquí y este
punto de aquí los dos puntos donde se
intersectan y bueno como tengo funciones
que no son lineales de una manera
algebraica se ve muy difícil encontrar
para que x se satisface esta ecuación de
aquí así que la mejor manera o lo que te
recomiendo para encontrar los puntos de
intersección de estas dos curvas es
utilizar la calculadora y estimar cuál
es la solución de esta igualdad que
tengo aquí para eso qué te parece si
utilizamos una tabla voy a poner en esta
tabla por aquí ld x ok vamos a ver qué
es lo que pasa o cómo se comporta ld x 0
del punto en donde estamos buscando la
intersección
por otra parte voy a poner aquí rd x
aquí también voy a escribir
x ok y bueno lo que voy a hacer variar
es a x por lo tanto aquí voy a poner a x
y justo así va a estar mi tabla así que
déjame hacer una tablita por aquí vamos
a hacer una tabla y para esto voy a
utilizar este color ok
aquí va a estar mi tabla y voy a bajar
por acá algo más o menos así porque
además me impiden dos puntos entonces
vamos a hacerlo para dos puntos por lo
tanto va a ser un poco larga esta tabla
algo más o menos así y voy a ir variando
x entre un rango de décimos que es lo
que me piden entre un rango de 0,1 voy a
ir variando x cerca de los puntos de
intersección para ver en qué punto se
aparecen más estas dos curvas y en el
punto en decimos en el que se parezcan
más estas dos curvas va a ser mi
solución así que para esto qué te parece
si empezamos a fijarnos en un punto
cercano cercano a este punto que tengo
aquí de rojo para qué tan lejos estoy
del punto de intersección así que bueno
este punto se ve muy cercano a uno por
lo tanto vamos a probar con uno con uno
para empezar o esperar y déjame cambiar
de herramienta así que déjame cambiar
para acá ahora tú sabes cuánto es el
logaritmo natural de 3 x cuando x vale 1
es decir el logaritmo natural de 3 bueno
tal vez te lo sepas de memoria pero al
menos yo no me acuerdo por lo tanto voy
a traer aquí la calculadora y vamos a
trabajar con ella voy a trabajar aquí
con la calculadora y vamos a ver primero
qué es lo que me sale de el logaritmo
natural de 3 y después de esta función
evaluado en 1 por lo tanto vamos a
empezar el logaritmo natural que está
justo aquí el logaritmo natural de 3
cuánto es bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que
1.0 9
861 ok vamos a apuntarlo antes de que se
nos olvide
1.098 6 1 punto
oh espera déjame cambiar de color
déjenme cambiar de color y es l de x ok
entonces es con este color me queda
1.098 6 vamos a ver qué diferencia hay
con rd x
1.098 6 vamos a tener otra vez aquí a la
calculadora a donde están aquí esta
1.098 6 y ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
con rx y lx es toda esta función de que
arriban entre x pero x vale 1 así que lo
podemos calcular de hecho de una manera
muy fácil 1 al cuadrado menos 1 esto es
0 + 1 entre 1 a eso está muy fácil hasta
podemos prescindir de la calculadora
porque eso es lo mismo que uno déjenme
tenerlo aquí esto es lo mismo que 1 que
uno por lo tanto fíjate que cuando x
vale 1 l de x que es esta gráfica de
azul vale
1.098 6 y rd x que es esta gráfica esta
gráfica de verde que tenemos aquí vale 1
ahora si te das cuenta en este punto nos
está ocurriendo lo siguiente r tx está
más abajo está más abajo que lo que vale
el de xl de x está un poquito más arriba
por lo tanto no es el punto de
intersección nos estamos acercando pero
todavía no encontramos el punto de
intersección de hecho se ve claramente
aquí en esta gráfica que está un poquito
antes que 1 así que qué te parece si
probamos con amd vamos a intentarlo con
cero punto org así que tomemos otro
nuevo valor
0.8 y vamos a ver cuánto vale ld x y
redex vamos a ver a saquemos la
calculadora y primero voy a calcular el
logaritmo natural de 3
por 0.8 por
0.8 ok y cuánto es esto a
0.87 54 87 54 87 54 87 54
0.87
54 ok ahora veamos qué es lo que pasa
con r de x r tx ok vamos a la
calculadora que está justo por aquí
perdón olvidaba que estaba por aquí y
podemos escribir toda esa función con
0.8 y que me quedaría bueno vamos a
tener cuidado con los paréntesis me va a
quedar
0.8 elevado al cuadrado que está justo
aquí ok menos menos aquí está al menos
menos
0.8
uno más uno todo esto todo esto por eso
lo atrape entre este paréntesis todo
esto es dividido entre 0.8 y esto va a
ser igual a ok
1.0
51.05 vamos a ver qué pasó
tengo aquí
1.051 o espera
punto
05 si te das cuenta en este caso se
invirtieron los papeles en este caso
estamos am y dejando cambiar de color en
este caso pasa lo siguiente
estamos viendo que cuando x vale 0.8 ld
x l de x es ahora menor es un poco menor
que lo que vale hoy que fue color déjame
cambiar a un color más llamativo a este
l de x es un poco menor que lo que vale
ahora rx r de x está arriba de lo que
vale ld x estrellas cuenta cambiaron los
papeles por lo tanto debe de haber algún
punto intermedio a que se aproxime más
entre estos dos o dicho de otra manera
el punto de intersección está entre
estos dos ahora como a nosotros nos
piden que estimemos la solución dentro
de los decimos bueno pues ya está
podemos concluir que la solución es 0.9
que es el punto que está justo en medio
de los dos 0.9 es el punto que está en
medio de los dos
acabaríamos porque estoy segurísimo que
es el punto que mejor estima esta
solución ahora sí que es lo podríamos
comprobar tú y yo con la calculadora así
que vamos a hacer lo vamos a sacar la
calculadora que estaba justo por aquí y
primero calculemos el logaritmo natural
de 3
por punto 9 ok y esto es igual a
0.9
932 0.99 32 así que voy a ponerlo con
este color
0.9
932 ok y vamos a ver qué pasa con r de x
rx a dónde está mi calculadora está por
acá
ok rx me sale de evaluar y hay que poner
paréntesis punto 9 al cuadrado esto
menos dónde está el menos menos punto 9
todo esto más 1 y todo esto dividido
entre punto 9 lo voy a dividir entre
punto 9 y esto lo mismo que
1.011 11 entonces voy a ponerlo a esto
es lo mismo esto es lo mismo que
1.01
1 y date cuenta que aquí estamos muy
cerca muy pero muy pero muy cerca del
punto de intersección mejoramos de estar
aquí a estar aquí y aquí estamos mucho
más cerca de las dos funciones que lo
que estamos aquí y como nuestros
resultados nos lo piden en decimos
podemos asegurar que al menos el primer
punto de intersección donde más nos
acercamos o donde mejor estimamos la
solución en donde estas funciones son
iguales o el punto intersección es justo
este de aquí 0.9 así que ya tenemos uno
de ellos ahora vamos a estimar el otro y
para eso déjame separar que estos dos
son ejercicios distintos ok bueno es el
mismo problema pero estamos hablando de
dos puntos distintos y ahora empecemos a
estimar cerca de este punto de aquí que
si te das cuenta estamos entre 2 y 3 y
creo que es como
2.8 vamos a intentar con 2.8 o 2.9 a
2.8 que pasa cuando tengo 2.8 así que
bueno de la misma manera voy a traer
aquí mi calculadora donde está aquí esta
calculadora y vamos a hacer lo mismo el
logaritmo natural de 3
2.8 ok esto es igual a
2.12 82 entonces vamos a escribirlo 2.2
2.12 82 ok y ahora vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa con rd x cuando x vale 2.8
entonces deja mente de la calculadora
2.1 282 2 puntos 282 y vamos a calcular
para 2.8 crd x a
2.8 elevado al cuadrado ya esto le quito
2.8 y a esto le sumó 1 ok y todo esto lo
voy a dividir entre 2.8 y esto es lo
mismo que
2.15 71 2.15 71 a dejan escribir lo aquí
2.15 71 71 ok y ahora vamos a ver qué es
lo que está pasando lo que está pasando
es lo siguiente
el dx es más pequeña pero por muy poco
que heredé x el dt x es más pequeña ok
se ve justo aquí que herede x pero por
muy muy poco así que nos tenemos que
fijar en un punto hacia la izquierda
ahora tante cuenta que estamos muy pero
muy pero muy cercanos así que qué te
parece si lo intentamos con 2.7
2.7 y vamos a hacer lo mismo
así que saquemos la calculadora ok y
logaritmo natural de 3 por
2.7 y vamos a ver cuánto es esto
2.0
2.0 918
918 ok y vamos a ver qué pasa con rd x
vamos a ver qué pasa con r de x y en red
de x es y abrimos paréntesis
2.7 elevado al cuadrado menos menos 2.7
ya esto le sumamos 1 y todo esto lo
dividimos entre 2.7 a ok esto es lo
mismo que
2.0 703 o que nos vamos acercando
2.070 3 con este color
2.070 3 ok estamos muy pero muy pegados
date cuenta que ahora pasa justo lo
contrario esto quiere decir que cuando
yo me fijo en 2.7 y déjenme cambiar de
color a este color
cuando yo
y el valor de x por 2.7 encuentro que el
de x es a mayor el de x es ligeramente
mayor que estamos justo desde aquí que
herede x rx es un poco menor por lo
tanto el punto de intersección estaría
entre ellas dos ahora como nos piden que
estimemos las soluciones hasta decimos
ya no me puedo acercar más porque si me
acerco más estaría estimando la solución
en centésimos y yo lo que quiero es en
decimos por lo tanto me tendré que
quedar con alguna de estas dos o 2.8 o
2.7 y si te das cuenta la más cercana es
o no se ve tan claro así que qué te
parece si sacamos la calculadora y vemos
cuál es la más cercana de las dos y aquí
me tengo que tomar la diferencia de
punto 15
71 71 menos a menos 12 82
es punto entonces borremos punto 12 82
ok aquí es
0.02 89 y si nosotros vemos en 2.7 hay
que tomar me la diferencia de puntos 0 9
18 - punto 07 03 ok y esto es
0.02 15 por lo tanto está más cercano
esté 2.7 que esté por poquitito así que
vamos a verlo el más cercano es este de
aquí aunque el punto de intersección
esté entre estos dos y de igual manera
aquí si te das cuenta no es exacto el
punto de intersección sin embargo en
esta función r tx sigue siendo mayor que
el de x aquí r tx sigue siendo
ligeramente mayor que herede x estamos
aquí y por lo tanto podemos asegurar que
el punto de intersección con completa
exactitud está entre 0.9 y 1 pero bueno
si lo que queremos y lo que tenemos que
poner de respuesta es cuál es el número
que más se acerca hasta decimos bueno ya
tenemos que es 0.9 y 2.7 aquí están las
dos mejores estimaciones de en el punto
de intersección de estas dos curvas o
del valor de x en donde el de x es igual
a rd x nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo